did you watch the grammys um
what did i watch i watched
let's see
i actually don't remember what i watched
from the grammys i watched part of the
watt performance then i watched trevor
noah read those
[ __ ] god awful teleprompter bits
what were they oh it was so bad like
they did [ __ ] cardy and megan
and then at the end of it it's just
cardi
on the late part of the set was a giant
bed
and so cardi was standing on it and then
trevor walks onto it
and he's like i've always dreamt of
being
in bed with cardi b
it was they did the sound effects too i
wish
it would have been real wait was the
point was the point that the
teleprompter bits were purposely cheesy
i don't think whoever wrote i don't
think they thought they were cheesy huh
the best part was the ceo
of uh the recording academy or whatever
um he's like we understand there's been
complaints and you know
we want to um we want to honor that and
and build an academy
it's like don't work against us work
with us
and i was like wow that's crazy that
the grammys actually feels compelled to
acknowledge that everyone thinks the
grammys are [ __ ]
yeah yeah because they are
i mean yeah completely and then you know
um what else
beyonce i just read beyonce most awarded
singer but i read that as
beyonce awarded most singer
and the winner of most singer goes to
beyonce
beyonce you are just the most singer
she's like i want to thank everyone as
the most singer
um uh yeah who else won who else won
one and dua lipa won every
man in america's heart didn't see the
performance can't speak to it
oh i just saw some twitter pictures and
a lot of people going ape [ __ ] over it
yeah you just kind of look at twitter
occasionally and i would just see
artists names with exclamation marks
i just kind of like to imagine different
things that they were doing up there
like dooley was just severing some guy's
head
[Laughter]
yeah skinny chicken won't believe what
she did this year for her performance
she killed a man crazy outfit or what no
she literally murdered someone
on stage
that's what it's gonna be because like
you know they keep every year they they
gotta push the envelope a little bit
like
yeah or they have like billy eilish and
alicia keys perform together or
something like that
you know it's always like crazy collabs
and like let's get this person on stage
with this person
blah blah blah yeah it's just gonna be
crazy performance art like the box
oh man that was that was so weird
like roddy got in there and was like you
know he's really harmonizing that [ __ ]
who roddy rich like he sang the box and
he was like singing it it was it was
very different no i meant the box in
london like the club
oh [ __ ] i thought you're talking
about roddy's performance that was
you know it was impressive but it was
just threw me off
oh he was like singing it sort of yeah
it was like a weird he's like
he's like oh my god
yeah he's got incredible he's got some
pipes on him
go relax he's i'm just saying dude's got
a set of pipes
um let's play this got a nice pipe uh
play the uh among
us cody suss
dude's got pipes
you
people won people lost
the ceo being like please don't cancel
us that was that was funny
what i was having there um freddie gibbs
had a great quote
oh i saw that i think i saw what did he
say again i might have lost today
but i'm undefeated in court
that was good yeah and he had that fly
pink suit on super fly suit
yeah i'm just i just think it's so dope
that freddy you know he's just been
making music forever
it's always good now he's getting on
fallon
he's getting nominated for [ __ ] and he's
like 40 something isn't he you're close
to it yeah
yeah that's always inspiring yeah
i mean man i don't want to get all
whatever but it is something to be
committed to your craft for that long
and
and always being consistent i think
that's very hard to do
yeah because you know no i agree i
hundred percent agree
yeah it's inspiring whenever you see
tweets of people in like uh
michael keaton had his first role when
he was 65.
[Music]
keep going keep going yeah
it could be today yeah but here's the
thing it is most likely too late
yeah for most of us it's too late if
you're over
28 it's probably too late to achieve
your dreams if you're over 19 it's too
late to achieve your dreams basically
if you're yeah nowadays actually if
you're over 19 if you haven't gotten
rich by 19
it's not gonna happen yeah if you're not
like um
absurdly famous and every brand is
trying to integrate in every aspect of
your life and can
psychologically [ __ ] ruin you with
money
at 17 years old it's probably too late
that's what we got to say in those
college zoom calls
yeah we get we get books for these like
for colleges can book us for like zoom
calls we'll do like q and a's for
colleges and [ __ ] like that
and there's always like some supposed to
be some theme where like people will hit
us up and
or ask us questions ollie peter we're
always like
people are always like what kind of
advice would you give college students
we should be like
you should you should have dropped out
two years you shouldn't
should have never went to college you
should be doing drop shipping right now
yeah you should have learned how to lip
sync that's what you should
yeah yeah exactly the fact that yeah
you're not
insanely [ __ ] rich at 18 is is a
problem
yeah you see the way inflation's going
by the time you're 25 you need to be a
millionaire to buy bread
okay yeah exactly i hope to god you all
of bitcoin please tell me you do
you don't oh god i mean what are we even
doing here this
class is hopeless man
i'm like i'm starting to like develop
weird conspiracy thoughts about bitcoin
it's probably because you know i'm just
upset that i didn't hold on to any
okay put it what are your conspiracies
it's not really a conspiracy it's just
something seems
off that a thing with no
actual application like there's no
real place that it's
actually used you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah the technology is interesting
and you can buy weed in like slovenia
with bitcoin right and then there's a
coffee shop that accepts it
and there's a random atm in russia that
it works at
but other than that bitcoin it
doesn't you don't do anything with it so
how can something
with no real use have the value of 65
000
per one unit that's just crazy well it's
the scarcity
it's the scarcity someone said there was
a tweet or something like that said
there's an abundance of scarcity right
now
it's like well you could not better put
into words
with what's going on with nfts yeah and
all the different altcoins that you can
own
it's like an abundance of scarce it
means like
there's two there's too much scarcity
like every every
nft that gets minted is like one of one
it's like oh it's automatically worth
something because it's scarce it's like
no but there's
a billion of these right now people are
[ __ ] minting pictures of their boobs
and balls and whatever it's like it's
not scarcity anymore it's just
yeah it's just the internet it's just
google images
something just feels off about all of
this man
who knows no i don't i think i do again
i think that bitcoin nfts everything is
definitely where i mean it's like long
term i think
it's absolutely um a tried and true test
of technology at this point that's gonna
like
last but i think that it does feel a
little bubbly right now
yeah you know it's just yeah it just
feels a little bubbly i don't say
there's anything wrong with it
just something feels a little bit off
you know
that's all yeah you just sound like a
hater yeah you sound [ __ ]
old dude yeah
yeah just wait just wait till we're all
trillionaires we'll be laughing
you